so if anyone was disappointed with the
fact that Martin Scorsese's last film
Hugo was technically a family movie this
should work everything out the wolf of
Wall Street is directed by Martin
Scorsese one of my favorite directors
one of the best filmmakers of our time
stars Leonardo DiCaprio Jonah Hill
Matthew McConaughey and the hottest
woman I have seen in movies all year so
in this movie Leonardo DiCaprio plays a
real-life person named Jordan Belfort
this guy is a stockbroker who lives to
make money he dreams about money I mean
it's all he thinks about day and night
money money money money he can't get
enough of it he eventually starts his
own agency where he's got his own people
working form including Jonah Hill where
they do various corrupt things that
aren't exactly by the book to make money
and this movie explores that world of
super rich Wall Street brokers who are
extremely corrupt and we've seen movies
like that before you know like Wall
Street but never one that explores it in
such detail
that's how I'll put it this is a good
movie Martin Scorsese that is a
filmmaker that is that is a filmmaker
there is still someone out there who
makes movies that I can go to a theater
and I can I could watch his movies I'm
not even exaggerating this guy is a
director he can make such fantastic
scenes filled with vibrant camerawork
and he is so good at taking the camera
and making that camera give you the
point of view of his characters and
making the camera Express what his
characters are feeling at that moment he
is so good at that and there are so many
fantastically entertaining scenes in
this movie certain scenes that go on
longer than you may think and you can
tell okay this is gonna be a big scene
right now this movie was so entertaining
and I'm not just talking about fun
because it is a very funny movie
probably Scorsese's funniest film I'm
because I've seen a lot of his comedies
and many of them did not reach the
heights of the hilarity in this movie I
really like the king of comedy with
Robert De Niro I think that's a very
underrated movie especially for Scorsese
but this movie is like a scene two-seam
laugh riot is because the actors
are so invested in their characters
Leonardo DiCaprio that guy is an actor I
mean there are people out there who act
you know and that's what they do for a
living
this guy is one of the best actors we
have and the reason I say that
truthfully because this guy is given a
lot of great performances this is one of
those times where I start to not see him
you know Leonardo DiCaprio I see his
character because he is so phenomenally
invested in this character the various
acts of debauchery this guy commits he
sells every word out of this guy's mouth
fantastic in this movie now Jonah Hill
was Oscar nominated for Moneyball this
role that he has in this movie crushes
every performance he's ever given he is
so good in this movie because again
that's another actor we're getting to
the point where okay it's Johnny ilyas
as Jonah Hill isms and you can tell
certain things he's gonna do and he's a
funny guy like I'm quite a bit and this
is the end
Moneyball he's done good performances in
the past two is super bad like Leo
DiCaprio you start to see that character
you start to view that person as a
person not just Jonah Hill there were
scenes in this movie that were so
freakin hilarious that I was literally
holding my sides my abs were starting to
cramp up from laughing one scene in
particular which I will not spoil where
a character starts to realize the
intense side effects of a drug that he
has ingested that he was not expecting
100% one of the best scenes I have seen
this year blew my mind the audience in
my theater was just dying it was great
they were laughing so hard I couldn't
even hear some of the dialogue that was
being spoken Rob Reiner in this movie
what we're sort of like watching a
Quentin Tarantino movie where he takes
an actor who's kind of been out of the
limelight for a while and just brings
him into this amazing role Rob Reiner
killed it in this movie he was very good
and Matthew McConaughey man I respect
that guy so much he has turned his
entire career around in these past few
years he was great in this film I just
thought Dallas buyers club I will have a
review up for that soon but that guy is
really crushing it in every movie he's
in nowadays this movie has so much to
say about the way people on Wall Street
are back then and nowadays suddenly
watch this film and think that because
it's so funny that it's condoning these
various acts that are so bad or that
it's being irreverent and it's saying
yes this is fine and you can be that way
it's really not because there's always
consequences and the film doesn't shy
away from the fact that there are dire
consequences to living this type of life
now the film is very long it's three
hours long I think by one minute it's
Scorsese's longest film I think casino
was like a 1 minute less or something
like that I'm not sure but it is a
little totally inconsistent from time to
time but the fact that this movie is
three hours long and a comedy and drama
and a serious film and this and that all
wrapped into one and Scorsese was able
to maintain that much focus is
absolutely astoundingly remarkable for
that reason I gotta give this film an A
I think it's fantastic the only reason
it doesn't get an A+ because I said it's
slight tonal inconsistencies from time
to time the wolf of Wall Street is a
fantastic film that film lovers must see
so what's your favorite Martin Scorsese
film mine is the departed or the
depotted as I call it deep potted like
Boston you you got it if you understood
what I was going for I will have my
picks for the top best films of the year
very soon as well as the bottom worst
that's gonna be fun that'll be up next
week thanks as always for watching guys
and if you like this you can click right
here and get stuck my next
[Music]